his choice in reaction south carolina
senator lindsey graham
senator am i wrong is that that's the
agenda to me that works for the country
yeah but but the question of the
conference is a time for choosing
what i would tell the people putting on
the conference the republicans have
already chosen
they've chosen an american first agenda
to rally the party around
and if the primary were held tomorrow
president trump would win
if he chose to run going away so the
question really is
does anybody in the republican party
doubt that the american first agenda is
the way to move forward
and here's the question i have if
president trump decides to run
in 2024 and he wins the party's
nomination
will you support him it's a time for
choosing in that regard
would you support president trump if
he's our nominee every republican needs
to be asked that question
you know for for the house to have in
the biden obama year
65 show votes to repeal and replace
obamacare
and then not be ready with their plan in
2017
speaks volumes about that old republican
party
for seven republican senators your
colleagues
to vote in 2015 for a clean repeal bill
of
obamacare and then when it mattered then
when it would have been signed into law
they seven of them backed away from
their vote two years earlier
that's the old weak establishment
republican party
i don't see that as a viable alternative
anymore
so this this whole conference says how
would you define being a republican
i would look at what president trump did
and i would choose that as my way
forward
that we believe in strong borders we
believe in a strong military
that we're expecting people to do more
to help themselves america can't be
everything to everybody
all the time we believe in lower taxes
we believe in free and fair trade and
not being a chump when it comes to trade
so the bottom line is if you're running
for president or thinking about running
for president
are you smart enough to embrace the
american first agenda
and the question for the republican
party right now is if donald trump
ran uh for in the primary
he would win going away and the question
is why
why would why are so many republicans
willing to give him
another shot at this because they
believe in what he did and they believed
his policies worked
and if you don't see that if you don't
get that then you really don't
understand the republican party in 2021
so what's the point i see that the
establishment figures are trying
that's the question okay what i see
is is they're fighting a cold war
against those that support the make
america first
uh great again agenda and an america
first agenda
um i don't think they have a prayer they
can try as hard as they want but
if you have candidates that don't
support those simple principles that i
believed in my whole career
i'm not gonna i will no longer support a
rhino i'm not doing it
well i think what they're trying to do
is convince people who may be running in
2024
that the trump agenda is not the right
formula for success
and i respectfully disagree if you want
to
make the republican party strong all
over the country and you want to win in
2024
we need to embrace the policies of
president trump that worked
so this idea of having a conference
trying to figure out what the republican
party should do and be
to me is sort of nonsensical we know
what it should be
it should be an american first agenda
and if president trump runs
he's going to have some damage to repair
but i think he's in great shape to win
the primary and could get re-elected
and my question is if he's the nominee
would you support him i'd like to hear a
lot of people answer that question well
let's see if they
get asked that question at this little
sorry they have it at the reagan library
all right
senator thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else